corporations loom large but the boot on
the neck of the working man
looms larger the future is already here
it's just not evenly distributed in knit
runner you either become
a money hungry monolithic leviathan that
is a corporation in this capitalist
hellscape or you become
a hacker a knit runner who like a mouse
in the walls
scurries around the corporation eating
away at their foundations
narrowly escaping the press of their
boot
the most important thing to know about
netrunner is that it's entirely
asymmetrical that means that unlike
other games like magic the gathering
where everyone can play the same cards
and has a similar sort of setup you know
everyone has a take a card play monsters
attack
that sort of turn the turns and the way
that you play in the runner are
totally different dependent on whether
you play as a net runner
or as one of the corporations they use
entirely different decks with entirely
different cards
entirely different abilities different
ways to win different ways to lose
and probably the most important
difference between the two of them is
that the runner always plays their cards
face up so the corp knows what they're
up against but
the corp gets to place their cards face
down so when the runner goes up against
them they're not always sure what
they're going to encounter
generally a game will work like this the
corporation wins by protecting and
scoring these agenda cards which kind of
give them victory points
they have to place them down and then
protect them with ice
which is kind of like a firewall the
runner then has to try and hack into
these servers that the corporation sets
up
break through the ice with their cards
and steal that agenda for themselves
allowing them to gain the victory points
instead it's a relatively unique setup
for a card game because one player is
always on the defensive they're trying
to set up a fortress
while the other player is always on the
offensive trying to break down those
walls
but there's a couple of quirks in
netrunner that make it just so much more
creative
unique and fun to play for one the
neuron is not always going to turn up
this card and find agendas in these
servers
no the corporation can lay devastating
traps for the runner destroying their
hand getting rid of their cards dealing
brain damage so part of the way that you
play as the corp is trying to mislead
and bluff them as to where you're
keeping your agendas
where you're trying to score points so
they don't know where to attack
and because the corporation gets to
place their cards face
down the runner when they're coming up
against them doesn't always know what
they're gonna find
and then they turn it over and oh no i
can't stop but i haven't got the tools i
haven't got the programs and it does
three net damage so for the runner
it's a game of hedging your bids trying
to figure out now's the time to strike
you're never going to be able to respond
to every kind device they can put down
but you've got to run before the
corporation gets too
powerful mechanically netrunner is
really creative but i think that what
sets it apart from other card games
like magic gathering even more is that
you are
much less dependent on the cards that
you draw
and that's because the setup that you
create the cards that you
get down on the board cannot be so
easily destroyed by your opponent in one
or two turns a plan that you build up to
for ages and it's just over it's just
gone
seeing a massive monster come out on the
board can mean game over in a couple of
turns
but equally your massive monster that
you paid everything to get
can be murdered with a really cheap card
and that's just
your whole plan gone netrunner is not
nearly as temperamental the ice that the
corporation puts out cannot be destroyed
by the netrunner and the netrunner's
programs and hardware and resources are
pretty
hard for the corporation to destroy it
won't happen very often in a game
you're not really waiting for a big
powerful card to win you the game
in other words because plans are not
dependent on
and cannot be so easily undone by chance
netrunner is a game that's a lot more
dependent on your planning
and your skill now to be fair this does
mean the netrunner is probably a slower
paced
game than you might be used to you know
it doesn't have that constant
boom and collapse that comes from cards
rapidly entering the battlefield and
exiting the battlefield and exciting
moments it's and that is exciting don't
get me wrong but it's not what this
game is so much about uh there is
instead this
rising tension across the game you know
where choosing your moment is really
important it's crucial
if i make a run now he won't put down
another piece of ice to defend that
agenda
but i might not have enough to get
through whatever that card is
at its heart near runner is a game about
bluffing and choosing your moment to
strike
and i think that's a wonderful shift
away from other card games where it's
just about
knowing and learning a million key words
i'm about to win i attack your monster
it's weak right now aha
but it's got bedazzle what does that
mean it means i do 10 damage without
paying for it ugh
well how was i meant to know that it
doesn't even say it on the card yeah
anyway i attack you and i win now
the slow pace doesn't mean that there
aren't those same aha i got you moments
because there are there
are great feedback loops for the runner
and the corp when the runner gets
through the ice and
manages to steal an agenda or destroy a
valuable card and it's
incredibly satisfying when the runner
spends all of their money and all of
their actions are
trying to get through your ice and then
suddenly it's a trap
and they get damaged they lose all their
cards that's also really great but those
are things you build to over several
turns
gradually they're not something that
you'll keep in your hand and then throw
down on the table so much
this is all complimented by something
that i find pretty important in games
and that's
theme i like games that disguise the
maths that i am doing
and netrunner it totally succeeds at
this
the designers went out of their way to
use terms that really reinforce this
cyberpunk
theme you know they they kind of get you
to think about the stuff that you're
doing
in cyberpunk terms they took a lot of
the words by the way from william
gibson's
neuromancer a book that i reviewed and
you can go watch up in the
corner right now or after the video it's
stuff like ice
icebreaker stack rig netrunner the names
of
quite a number of the cards i actually
read and i was like hey i recognized
that
so it is really a gorgeous game
thematically and i really like that
but i think even more so what makes
netrunner so immersive as a game is the
asymmetricality again between the runner
and the corp
because the different styles of play
really embody the differences
between them in the world itself the big
lumbering corporation only gets three
actions per turn because it's a
bigger slower entity while the
independent
fast thinking netrunner gets four the
runner can lose when they take brain
damage and die because they're hooking
their mind into this machine
the corporation on the other end is
trying to track the runner down they're
trying to put these tracking tokens
on the other player because they live in
secret they're trying to find to them
i will admit that there is one element
of the gameplay that is
weirdly unfamatic and that's that it's
oddly enough
easier to get rich as the net runner
than it is as the corporation
and that's kind of a consequence of how
the game works if the corp also had a
crap ton of money then there would be no
way for the netrunner to win
but it is still kind of strange and i
still plan to go i wish there was a way
for the court to be the one with the
money it feels weird when you win as the
netrunner because you outspend the
corporation i mean you should really win
through subterfuge shouldn't you
however it does need to be said that
netrunner is
not an even-handed game it is harder to
play as the corporation than it is to
play
as the runner it's harder to learn the
strategy for playing the court
when and which cards you should play the
runner has the advantage in the early
game because the corp can't defend
everything that they need to protect
and in the late game they can break
through almost anything you have a
narrow window of victory in the middle
of the game
now this isn't a bad thing by itself but
it can
feel unfair especially when you're
learning and it
magnifies any skill differences between
you
and the other player that you're playing
up against and some people do like games
where it's always going to be
even-handed no matter which faction you
choose to play with especially if you
like one play style more but it's always
harder to win
that would kind of suck but i think
just like in this monster
psy not every faction is you know
equally powerful there are clearly a
couple of factions in scythe one of the
most popular games in the world
which are better than others and that's
okay
you know it creates a different strategy
it creates different challenge and it's
just important to recognize
that winning as the corporation is more
of an achievement in many ways than
running as
than winning as the runner connected to
this is the problem of steamrolling i
have noticed that if
one side gets a car that gets them a lot
of money early in the game then they do
tend to win a lot more easily because
the only way to stop them is by spending
money and it just creates the cycle
where you know you'll go up against them
you'll fail they'll get more money
you'll get less
and then the game's over from that point
but i mean that is
partly the nature of card games there's
always going to be an element of that
when there's resource management
and i think it's worth remembering that
you always play for the good games not
the occasional bad one
now netrunner is a pretty deep and
complicated game which can make it
really hard to teach because obviously
you're playing asymmetrically as well
you're putting down your cards in one
way and they're going where do i put
mine you go well you've got to find this
card and put it down in this position
it's just it's just it can be a bit
difficult but complexity isn't a bad
thing
spirit island is an immensely complex
game to learn
and play well but it is consistently the
one that
everyone i teach it to wants to play a
game but it does mean that netrunner
is not just a casual game that you can
whip out with anyone teach them in 10
minutes and
have a good game of it it will take a
few games to get used to so it's a lot
better
if you have someone that you can
regularly play with a partner
or a close friend who likes these sorts
of games i do tend to find that
and of course netrunner is only a two
player game so if you only have your
partner or a friend to play with then
this
may be better a lot of games are
designed to be better with more and more
people
and it can be hard to get a whole group
together that can consistently
you know play but netrunner is designed
for two players
it is how it works best that's when it's
most fun
so getting another card game which is
designed for more may not be the best
option when you go for this
the base game also comes with several
different runners and
different corporations that you can play
with which all have again different play
styles different strengths and
weaknesses
but deck building in netrunner is a lot
more restricted or perhaps complicated
than it is in a lot of games
and the game is not designed around
encouraging you to create your own deck
so much
which i appreciate that a lot of other
people really do
like um and that's okay so if you are a
dick builder you can create your own
destiny runner but
it's not really the same as you might be
used to i think netrunner is for people
who
like card games but want one that allows
them to plan out and deliver on their
plans
more to see what they build up pay off
building a more elaborate economy and
strategy
than magic or hearthstone allow you to
at the moment
and who don't want you know expensive
plans blown apart
in a single turn by a cheap car that you
could not have seen coming
it's probably not for the people who
love that fast-paced
bombastic you know throwing cards down
getting them on the board getting them
off board
that instant cycle that a lot of people
really love if you like that then
maybe not for you we're being flexible
and having backup plan after backup
planner for backup plan
is key to winning it is for people who
love the cyberpunk genre and want to see
a game that truly replicates its themes
i think it should be pretty obvious that
i totally recommend it personally but i
would love to hear your thoughts on the
game and your thoughts on magic and
hearthstone and other games like
whether you feel i'm at all being fair
to them
let me know down below hope you enjoyed
this review
stay nerdy and i will see you in the
future